اجتمعوا في هذه اللحظات تحالف اوبك بلس في
فيينا لمناقشه وضع السوق النفطيه وتراجع
الاسعار في ظل مخاوف الركود الاقتصادي
والتضخ روبك بلس نحو 40% من الانتاج
العالمي للنفط الخام ما يعني ان قراراته
المتعلقه بسياسه الانتاج قد يكون لها
تاثير كبير على اسعار النفط
[موسيقى]
اهلا خالد الصوت عندي يتقطع بعض الشيء
ولكن
اليوم نشهده في اجتماع اوبك بلس المجموعه
حقيقه امام مشهد اقتصادي عالمي غامض خلال
الاشهر القليله الماضيه بالرغم من قيام
اوبك بلس في اكتوبر من العام الماضي
بتخفيض الانتاج بواقع اثنين مليون برميل
يوميا
شهدنا بعض الارتفاع في الاسعار لكن عادت
الاسعار من جديد للتراجع هذا دفع عدد من
اعضاء تحالف اوبك بلس بقياده السعوديه في
مطلع ابريل لاتخاذ تخفيضات طوعيه في
الانتاج اجمالي التخفيضات وقتها بلغت
مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا تضاف الى
الاثنين مليون برميل يوميا السابقه
فبالتالي مجمل التخفيضات الان تبلغ 3.7
مليون برميل يوميا تقريبا حتى نهايه العام
الحالي ولكن بالرغم من هذه التخفيضات في
الانتاج الاسعار
اسمعك الان خالد
قلت لك بانه بعض صفحات مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تحدثت عن مغادره
وزير النفط الانغولي لمقر الاجتماع دون
تحديد الاسباب هل ذلك صحيح
لم نتمكن من تاكيد ذلك بالرغم من انه
سمعنا هذه
الاخبار عن مغادرته
للمبنى نعرف بانه كان هناك اجتماع ليله
البارحه جمع وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير
عبد العزيز بن سلمان مع عدد من وزراء
الطاقه الافارقه الاعضاء في منظمه اوبك
بحسب الحديث الدائر بانه هناك مفاوضات حول
تخفيض خط الاساس لانتاج تلك الدول
الافريقيه خط الاساس هو الذي يحتسب منه
التخطيط لانه تلك الدول غير قادره اصلا في
الفتره الاخيره الوصول وتحقيق تلك
المستويات فبالتالي
هناك مفاوضات حول خفضها خط الاساس عاده
يحتسب خالد هو ما هي القدره الانتاجيه
القصوى لكل دوله اضافه الى حجم الانتاج
على فتره زمنيه تاريخيه سابقه يتم احتساب
خط الاساس ومنه يتم التفاوض حول حجم
التخفيض فبالتالي هناك حديث بان تلك الدول
الغير قادره على تحقيق تلك المستويات يجب
عليها تخفيض مستويات الاساس او خطوط
الاساس وهناك دول اخرى شهدت قدراتها
الانتاجيه زياده في الفتره الاخيره تطالب
بزياده خط الاساس لها فلربما هذا طبعا ملف
شائك لانه عاده الدول لا تحبذ ابدا ان يتم
تخفيض خط الاساس لها حتى لو انها غير
قادره في الوقت الراهن على تحقيق تلك
المستويات ولكن تحافظ على خط الاساس ذلك
للتفاوض عليه مستقبلا اذا لزم الامر موضوع
الانتاج الروسي كان ايضا مطار جدل خلال
الايام الماضيه ناصر ما طرحته او ما كتبته
لول ستريت جورنال عن خلافات بين الرياض
وموسكو حول هذا الامر او خروج روسيا عن
الاتفاق اتفاق بلس هذا الموضوع هل هو
مطروح ايضا في هذه الاجتماعات
خالد يعني التصريحات الرسميه من الجانب
الروسي كلها كانت تؤكد على متانه الشراكه
الروسيه السعوديه
الدور الايجابي بلس في المحافظه على
استقرار النفط نعرف بانه روسيا خلال
الاشهر الماضيه اوقفت الاعلان رسميا عن
مستويات الانتاج الرسميه لها في نوع طبعا
من
المعركه ما بين روسيا والغرب هي الان لا
تعلن رسميا عن الانتاجها من النفط هناك
مصادر ثانويه تحاول قياس تلك المستويات
ولكن يبدو بانه على الرغم من الانتاج وبغض
النظر عن حجم الانتاج الا ان نصادرات
روسيا النفطيه يبدو بانها لم تتاثر بشكل
كبير
بالمجمل لانه هناك زيادات كبيره جدا
بصادرات النفط الروسيه الى السوق الهنديه
والى السوق الصينيه بدانا نشهدها بشكل
كبير منذ بدايه هذا العام ما مدى تاثر ذلك
على اجمالي صادرات روسيا لانه نعرف بانه
روسيا الان بدات تصدر بكميات اقل بكثير
الى اوروبا ما هو صافي الاثر على صادرات
روسيا هذا ما زال غير واضح لكن روسيا الى
الان بشكل رسمي تؤكد على متانه الشراكه
الروسيه السعوديه في اداره السوق النفطيه
والمحافظه على استقرارها لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في
قناتنا تيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات